young welcome to this video playing crow
text son oops come on yeah from Croatia
right I got that one right the pretty
good GM I need to look it up double win
kuliah zibbic I think this is really a
2600 GM or something alright so
Rubinstein and I go for the new
variation the line that I am also
analyzed in my book many Muslims is the
the classic approach yeah this dates all
the way back from fish's muskie yeah
Queen a three year he say knows what
he's doing this is one of the lines that
i actually like form for white um so
what was my suggested way to play
against that I think it was a night age
seven but it's been a while since I
analyzed this of course it's a black
repertoire but this this Queen Queen f3
this slide was one of the ideas that I
really am thought them are worth
exploring for white yeah blacks problem
is this this night it's just an annoying
piece on f5 but you don't really want to
give up the bishop so I'm trying to
regroup my pieces that so that I have
from the possibility to take with the
night on e seven rook e8 intends to take
and Knight f6 and deform maybe he
retreats to ease
now then i will go back and prepare a
five again this is a very very difficult
structure to play at five is too early I
guess okay I think maybe I can take a
little bit to get the route 21 ya know
Quincy 8 + f5 was my my intention well
still i can maybe play night at five now
it doesn't so it probably doesn't
consider a five to be so great okay but
anyway i have put every piece um um yeah
I positioned every piece to to play this
move so no why use and delaying it yeah
this certainly cannot be the refutation
if there was any I mean I didn't I think
black was is okay in this this kind of
kind of line but Wow why would you give
me a temple maybe yeah maybe two to set
to do to put black inner in a pin Knight
f6 looks like a very natural moves to
play oh I didn't didn't think about that
yeah Bishop age six still the Queen I
mean isn't this this good really it
looks I don't know it looks a bit bit
too weird Queen doesn't have any square
hmm that's funny really interesting okay
let's just get out of this rook be one
she protect the beep on
g4 I can take this is important G for
Nyjah for Quincy forgive two very
important otherwise yeah I don't want to
think about otherwise and now if I go
look at fades YUM maybe you can take on
b7 because of this overloading but I
have thought that queen bee to create be
too will be 3m I thought that I have
enough counterplay queen bee three Queen
between looks like enough counter play
Queen d3 i have a form which is not
really calculated but takes Knight g4
Bishop f4 down
hmm
okay I don't know I let some and now
I'll play it if you weaken yourself more
i'll i'll do that even though if with
the misplaced broke on v8 ok this is
hanging
yeah but okay taking on d6 who gave to
it looks it looks dangerous I cannot
calculate the snow
and dangerous position check ideas queen
bee tuna or queen a to trying to get
those checks Queen the group G to check
hmm
not sure rookie to marry rookie to could
be am can take Quincy three check but
Queen f3 then looks like a decent
defense crinia three threatens Queen
aveda probably looking towards okay but
I could on cookie two up I can maybe
just retreat the rock to have six or
something great didn't see that at all
Queen 82 got the check and if I've check
I don't know if I can ops I cannot know
that but this doesn't look too bad
check him time warning
I don't know any tools
yeah I'm just check check check check
yeah okay I'll lose on time black for
fix all the time yeah I don't know it
was very complicated of course yeah I
have a computer set by kontan players
insufficient it just says white win cm
which is possible of course I mean it's
a I thought I might have enough counter
play which is certainly true and in this
position here I don't believe is
particularly grateful white cannot
believe that really I can also add in
just for argument's sake I can just take
what the Queen and I've never remotely
worse but Brooke Brooke effort just look
nice I didn't really think about this
venture thus Queen the Queen maneuver to
yeah probably this is this is the main
issue look f5 looks really nice because
of this temple but I can just take with
the rook there with the Queen I mean I
have formed and for as interesting I
didn't think about that
hmm ah this is there very very
interesting f for him the thing is at
first look at this position at first you
think that black is just winning in yeah
because if I exchanged looks I'm winning
this end game because of the bed pawn
structure his bishop was just a child
with peace I mean it looks like a
terrible piece but he's got exactly in
this position the chance and the
possibility to play a fourth and this is
just good now he intends to take and
what am I playing I cannot I cannot take
myself after that the bishop transforms
from a complete dummy on d22 to a great
piece winning the d6 bone fr is very
strong now I have a half I don't have a
good move against that can I can try
that that's not terrible for black but i
really thought i would have some some
substantial thing after the Kree trade
so okay probably rook takes Venice is
fine and now we just went all the way
here really curious yeah maybe I should
I don't have course not he can take on
age 6 this is actually what i briefly
considered like rook you know tip would
be one rupee eight and maybe exchange
added some like change gM now that I
have the knight on f6 on f4 I can play
moves like efore or on 94 maybe maybe
that way
hmm yeah i mean this probably wasn't so
terrible but it was it was shaky in a
way interesting what really is a
remarkable thing is is this a form with
this is something you hear this is very
very strong and I didn't really take
that into account alright thanks for
watching